my god yeah I made a t-shirt which I'm
now going to be wearing the [ __ ] out of
cuz I'm [ __ ] proud of it and you
can't do links in the description
I don't even Excel the shirt it sells
itself but if you did want something
cheaper since many of you weren't
enlightened by my last video bye hi
requests here is your animes trash and
so a my shirt for those of us who have
accepted the trash that we really are
cuz you know what else is trash attack
on Titus sorry I can resist you know I
saw something such a big fan of this
opening but after listening to it for
about 10 times well I can say wow right
to have the 6th season of attack and
fighting on with said and done now
regardless of our rub something is
coming week I've actually enjoyed it a
considerable amount even more so than
the first pieces so it comes as a little
surprise to me that no one's really
talking about it alright it's not really
that no one's talking about it you
counts are high then pretty much every
other show that season so obviously
people are watching it but the overall
spread and attention is getting is but
aspect to what it was in the first
season
they're the klieg knowledge ones are
this out the no real excitement or hype
surrounding it and it says volume so
this isn't a far more common
conversation to me the season though you
enjoying attack on titan after waiting
these four years yeah I mean it's cool
more unfortunately have you heard about
new Lord and Savior arrow Margo sensei
I see you two have reached enlightenment
there shows like Eromanga sensei and
boku no hero tournament archetype I've
been taking up all the discussions memes
and general attention within the enemy
community which one on the nine the
cheery mastery so there are manga so
today is certainly surprising
considering the rare worldwide
phenomenon the first season was in the
world of anime what happens is the
second season just a shadow of what came
before can hope for one of the hottest
anime ever die out that quickly always
error manga sensei really that good now
I have no doubt that many will have
found this season underwhelming with a
shift in tone and focus but it's for
that reason I've actually enjoyed it
more it's no longer the action-packed
bombastic door ride of season 1 but it's
introduced this mystery horror elements
there's much more of a focus on building
up side characters that moves at a
slower pace which in my opinion kind of
address some of the problems I had in
the first season a sacrifice in season 1
was always a thrilling and enjoyable but
ultimately kind of empty ride it thrives
on this interesting premise explosive
Direction constant twists and turns are
one of the strongest stars I can think
of in anime but after the series ended
everything felt a bit Hollow it didn't
feel that we got much actual progression
off the first few episodes due to the
slow down and pacing Titans went from
scary to stupidly funny and no
characters especially the main trio were
particularly well developed or engaging
we'd mourn the loss of characters not
because we were attached to them but
because they were useful to humanity or
had some key quirk in some way which was
shocking when they happened ultimately
didn't mean anything it was a show that
was exciting because of its shock factor
but as that wore off it ceased being
that special what this new season has
done in my eyes you stop trying to make
Titan this thrilling but empty ride it
starts off by stamping its mark with the
most gut-wrenching def sequence a series
i've seen so far reminding us that
titans are indeed terrifying even if the
designers still walk the fine line
between unsettling and stupidly
hilarious because
[Music]
yeah instead of all our action there are
quiet scenes of genuine tension and
horror which grounds the threat that the
Titans pose something that hasn't been
felt since the very beginning of the
franchise which I feel tied in well with
the whole mystery aspect of this reason
more information about the world is
revealed to us at a slow pace that keeps
us guessing it's an entirely new element
that builds off the foundation of the
previous season cliffhanger making us
question the nature of the world therein
and keeping us in a guessing game about
who is and isn't a Titan the fishery
aspects give you much more of an
interest in the water they've built
there wasn't just a continual reminder
that we need to go to Aaron's
all-important porn dungeons then we get
to the character focus which was a
pleasant surprise
especially with Aaron who knowing he was
one of the less interesting characters
in the car was given this revolutionary
and innovative character development
technique of removing him entirely from
the first after season I know right
[ __ ] revolutionary writing technique
that we should definitely use more often
we are more fearful slide characters
their motivation and history which I
appreciate it because now I can I should
be a bit more invested in what happens
in bumping instead of killing characters
for the sake of shock factor that we've
seen before now if there was a glaring
problem it's the fact that they had to
do this with about 20 [ __ ] flashback
every episode seriously there would be
scenes in the show that were like oh god
were surrounded by Titans we're all
gonna die yeah but do you remember that
time at Titan cam when you were being a
total stubborn [ __ ] Krista what the
[ __ ] is I got to do with anything yes we
had several episodes well half the damn
episode was a flashback but hey work
philosophy right so why shouldn't it
work here all this led to an experience
I wasn't quite expecting but I
definitely enjoyed more it was a
different direction than what we were
used to but something I feel would be
needed after the highest-paying first
season there were still twists and turns
but not in the way that you would think
the reveal for example was pretty
[ __ ] obvious for anyone paying
attention but the manner in which it was
done I think caught everyone off guard
leading to a brilliantly executed scene
and the one Titan 5 seemed in return out
to be a fast and intense flurry of blows
but a slower paced and one of the most
technical animated flights I've seen any
fans of Brazilian Jujitsu will get an
absolute hard-on for the sequence and
the time of watching an MMA fighter coin
I would absolutely love to analyze it
from four
if at the time but it's definitely my
favorite part of this franchise so far
regardless of order so I think I've been
enjoying the season so much more because
of the lack of hype surrounding it even
after all the praise I've given this
season I don't think it's exceptionally
standout in any given area mystery
horror character development a lot and
it's still brimming with flaws but was
the much more muted reception it's
gotten I was just allowed to enjoy it
for what it is attack on Titan is just a
very solid show and always was no
masterpiece by any means are still
highly enjoyable and I guess that the
advantage was less hype when every
little moment isn't being means each
intricate detail being dismantled and
analyzed over and over because no matter
how fond you are for a series there will
reach a point when you'll get bored
hearing about it discussing the same
points again and again with different
people seeing the same jokes passed
around and whether or not attack on
Titan was overrated is debatable whether
or not it was overhyped was
unquestionable but I think this muted
reception can be easily linked to how
our community receives new anime this
day and age or at least how many new
anime we watch in this current climate
we are seeing new seasons being
announced very soon after they first
ended or bizarrely having very old shows
being resurrected out of nowhere as
sacrifices didn't fit in either of these
councils I think the shows are important
it is to keep momentum going in the
world of anime on a technical standpoint
it did well to feel like no time at part
at all art in music will kept pretty
constant from the first season we didn't
get any subtle shifts as we often see
with other shows when there's a massive
time gap between seasons like Carrie he
for example where the designers ship it
has become slightly more Keanu fide so
no soundtrack it's also been very
similar to his previous works only
subtly adding bits and pieces here and
there so from a production standpoint it
honestly lives them feels like we've
just perished rate on where we left off
four years ago but that's the thing it
was four years ago as an anime community
we just move one very fast and he's
shown no matter how hot will be largely
old news in the matter of months when
the next season rolls around let alone
the years we had to wait for attack on
Titan we don't see this rise in
popularity seasons of season in the same
way we see with Western shows like
breaking bad or with the game of thrones
of today in fact it's the opposite a
series will rarely continue rising in
popularity per season unless we have
some kind of long-running shown in that
is ongoing without break and I don't
think there's a better candidate to
illustrate this and what we've seen with
attack on Titan and because it is I
think the show is the perfect case study
for how hyper
takes the perception of a show and how
quickly we move on as a community in the
end the biggest thing this season has
going against it aside from the four
year wait was its 12-episode run it's
done what it needed to do but there
aren't enough episodes to build up to a
proper climactic payoff so baffles me
with a thinking behind giving one of the
hottest anime properties of all the time
just 12 episodes of sambac its momentum
god knows how long we'll have to wait
see if we'll get a continuation so if
you hadn't converted to the manga
already I'm sure this short season will
convert even more people to the room
forever which is a shame because after
all this it's reminded me how enjoyable
the exact enticing frame can be the
season is far from perfect so it's
definitely a solid entry suffering from
having a long wait to see a middle child
trying its best to build up to something
bigger which still remains to be seen if
or when it happens it was a pleasant
change to what I was expecting and I'm
not sure everyone would have appreciated
it but with only the short season it
might ultimately not even mean much but
either way I enjoyed it regardless now
let's just hope it doesn't join the
likes of splice in wolf inheritance as I
grow a little shows that I as an anime
fan have just come to accept now that
I'll just never be able to see a season
3 old I'm not crying you're crying hey
guys hope you enjoyed the video thank
you very much this month to the mouth
potatoes Sam blue basil the watts juni
he may and everyone else impatient for
helping support me from this month and
making this video possible and I always
just saw like wisdom sidewalk were
having a 50% off deal for a clapping
side two manga till its 20th of June as
well so yeah then you know the deal
allows you didn't ask them so if you
want the t-shirts you get them in the
links in the description or the
annotations below haha I'm just out
[ __ ] jet today all right well I do
need all that spare gas for the
figurines of indie Wyatt ax
anyway that's it for me I've been gay
I'll see you all next time